- And don't get too worried about
what other people think
of you all the time.
We must allow for creative failure
when it comes to generating ideas.
It is inevitable.
That is because it is
only on our strengths
that can give us the energy
to correct our weaknesses.
I think the simplest thing
in dealing with disagreements
is get them onto the table.
Businesses are good at getting better
but poor at getting different.
- He's an Indian business tycoon,
investor, and philanthropist.
He's informally known as the
Czar of the Indian IT Industry.
He has an estimated net
worth of $16.5 billion.
He's Azim Premji, and her is my take
on his top 10 rules for success.
Number one is my personal favorite,
and I'm curious to figure out
which one you guys like the best.
- [Azim] You're asking me is
what should really motivate you.
- [Audience Member] Yeah.
- You know, I think that's
a very personal question
of what should really motivate you.
I think the longest standing thing
which should really motivate you
is that something in which
you're trying to quest
for something to satisfy yourself
and feel good about yourself.
And decide what that is,
and be constant to that purpose,
and try to work for
excellence in that area.
And don't get too worried about
what other people think
of you all the time.
We must allow for creative failure
when it comes to generating ideas.
It is inevitable.
No one likes failure,
particularly business leaders.
But unfortunately, all evidence suggests
that it is impossible to
generate few good ideas
without a lot of bad ideas.
And bad ideas are expensive,
but they have to be tolerated.
As the physics Nobel
Prize winner Fermi said,
"I try to fail as fast as I can."
That is the best way to
move forward on a new idea,
fail as fast as you can.
Failure should be forgiven and forgotten
as long as the lessons are
remembered and recycled.
You must begin life,
and you must approach
life with your strengths.
Absolutely essential.
Everyone in schooling very often
keeps on pushing one to focus
on what is wrong with us,
or tells us what is wrong with us.
And there is a very
interesting imaginary story
of a rabbit, and you must hear this one.
The rabbit was enrolled
in a rabbit school,
and like all rabbits,
it could hop very well
but could not swim.
At the end of the year,
the rabbit got high marks in hopping,
but failed in swimming.
The parents were concerned.
The relations were concerned.
The friends were concerned, the
elder friends, particularly.
They said, forget about hopping,
you are anyway good at it.
You don't have to keep practicing it.
Concentrate on your swimming.
They sent the rabbit for (mumbles)
and coaching in swimming,
and guess what happened?
The rabbit forgot how to hop.
(laughter)
As for swimming, have you
ever seen a rabbit swim?
(laughter)
While it is important for us to know
what we are not good at,
we must cherish what is good in us.
It's very fundamental to life.
That is because it is
only on our strengths
that can give us the energy
to correct our weaknesses.
To make changes in any organization,
you have to have a measure
of very high persistence.
You've got to go on,
and on, and on, and on.
If we don't have that persistency,
very often you fall out
just when success is around the corner.
The customer is a great source for ideas.
The customer can actually participate
in his getting better satisfaction,
provided we can listen to the customer
and what he or she has to say.
And I think this is the
most important thing
in terms of customer visits,
in terms of customer research,
is how do you get the customer
to say things, or indicate things,
or give nuances of things
which are really unsaid?
And very often the
customer himself or herself
does not know about it,
but that is the source of truly
very, very interesting ideas.
My friend was sharing with me a story
of his eight year old niece.
She would always complain
about the quality
of the breakfast and about
the quality of the food
she would get in the house.
She came from a family
where there was a cook,
and they tried just about
everything to please her.
Finally, my friend took
the child to a supermarket
and bought her one of these
ready-to-cook breakfasts.
The child had to cut the packet
and pour water in the dish.
After that, it took two
minutes in the microwave
to be ready.
The child found the food
to be absolutely delicious.
The difference was that she had cooked it
with her own hands.
She had put work and effort into it.
I have found that nothing
gives as much satisfaction
as earning our rewards.
A rupee earned is much more valuable
than five rupees found.
I think the simplest thing
in dealing with disagreements
is get them onto the table.
(laughter)
I think that nothing
breeds more discomfort,
and frustration, and anger with people
if you bottle them up.
That's very fundamental.
And you don't always win
when you get them onto the table,
but at least you come to
certain points of understanding,
which makes for people to move forward.
And you know, we, to run
large leadership positions
successfully, you can debate issues,
you can get issues onto a table.
But what you would expect is
that when a decision is made,
people fall in line going forward.
And if they have strong conviction
against the decision made,
it's best that they get out of the system
and don't frustrate themselves
and frustrate other
members of the colleagues
with their frustration.
As Gary Hamel puts it,
businesses are good at getting better,
but poor at getting different.
It is very difficult for
successful organizations
to develop destructive innovations
that would threaten the
basis of their success.
Often they are put out of business
when some similar company
or smaller company
develops a radically new technology.
Which employees working in
a booming telecom company
in the 1990s would have suggested
that free voiceover internet telephony
would be something that
they could develop?
It took a start up Skype to make a success
of this radical idea.
- When you talk about
ethics and integrating
in the Indian context,
the two companies that come to mind are,
one is (mumbles) and
the other is (mumbles).
What is so special about
these two companies
that has been imbibed
in these organizations?
How is it done?
- Very simple. It's done by practice.
There's no other way you imbibe things
in an organization.
It is practice.
Integrity is practice.
Leadership is practice.
Innovation is practice.
It's all practice.
You got to figure out what
you want your company to be
and what you consider is non-compromisable
and not negotiable.
And then send those out,
and keep them as simple as possible,
and keep them as few as possible,
and practice them.
And practice them every
day, every hour, ever minute
and have zero exception to it.
(mumbles) advice to
students who want to start
an organization like Wipro?
- Yes, sir.
- You know, the reality is
you have to start small.
(laughter)
Like we started small.
And you must have a
very clear understanding
of why you want to do it
and what focus you want to build.
And the focus you want to build
in terms of starting an organization
is something which must be
deeply passionate inside you.
Because you're going to
go through ups and downs.
In many cases, you're going to fail.
Certainly in parts of your journey,
you're going to have major failures.
So unless you have a very clear commitment
to the focus which you build
in terms of what do you
want to build successfully,
and have the flexibility
to change that focus,
because you've not judged
the market properly.
The markets don't run after you, you know.
You have to run after
what the market demand is,
what the market demand you can create.
But you have to be persistent,
and you have to be prepared
to make sacrifices,
because you will have to make sacrifices
in the early stages, and
some very major sacrifices.
And most of them will
be financial sacrifices.
Because you won't get cashflow
the way you hope to get cashflow,
unless you have a brilliant, genius idea,
then you'll get cashflow.
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video
because PRNV asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile,
leave it in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of the top 10 rules
had the biggest impact on you and why.
Leave it in the comments,
and I will join in the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe, or
whatever your one word is,
and I'll see you soon.